[Music]
and she is a human and she's nice and
she's loving if working with Abby Lee
Miller is really all that bad why is
Jojo still kickin it with her former
dance coach that's for her to know and
you to find out luckily we've got all
the deets and more watch until the end
to find out lime Abby might be a lot
nicer than we're led to believe the
original cast of Dance Moms wouldn't
dare think about returning to the ALDC
many of them have cut all contact with
Abby Lee Miller and would probably laugh
if she asked them to make an appearance
on Dance Moms season eight but there's
one dancer who has no issues with making
a splash in Pittsburgh it's no secret
that Abby Lee Miller never took it easy
on Jojo she constantly berated her
yelled at her and criticized her
performances you didn't change her
emotion but for some reason Jojo and
Abby are still on great terms so much so
that Jojo is making a guest appearance
in season 8 episode 9 anyone who has
watched Dance Moms from the very
beginning knows that working with Abby
isn't easy but why is it that Jojo who
never received special treatment is the
only one willing to work with her former
dance coach again well there could be a
lot of factors at play and while many of
us would love to see the original cast
make it guest appearances throughout the
new season it looks like Jojo was the
only one willing to bite the bullet
former dancers like Chloe Lucchese AK
and Nia Sioux will definitely not be
returning to the ALDC during an
interview with 2-day FM Abby was asked
about her former students and which ones
she kept in contact with I'm in touch
with Ashley Bruns mom as well as Jojo
and her mother jessalyn we know for a
fact that Abby and Kendall vertes have
also been in contact however none of the
og dancers would dare work with Abby
ever again Maddie Chloe and Kalani don't
have the patience for Abby anymore and
wouldn't dare give her the time of day
Abby's thrown so much shade their way
over the last few years that making a
guest appearance is strictly off the
table but if you really think about it
Abby has
rude - Jojo since the very beginning she
never received any special treatment and
was constantly being scolded for her
timing and attitude so you would think
that Jojo would get as far away from
Abby as possible yet for some strange
reason she's stayed by her side since
day one it's possible that Jojo was able
to maintain a healthy relationship with
her former dance coach because she has
thicker skin than the other girls I'm
really impressed how Jojo is taking this
all in while it's true that dodo often
cried on the set of Dance Moms
she always bounced back and had a
positive attitude about her JoJo's fame
also blew up after she appeared on the
show and hundreds of opportunities
opened up for her so being grateful
definitely played a factor in her
choosing to continue her relationship
with Abby on top of that
Jojo is spunky and able to take
criticism without making things personal
which is probably why Abby wanted her to
make an appearance in season 8 this way
Abby's new dancers could take a page out
of JoJo's book we've seen Abby and Jojo
get together on plenty of occasions but
some fans were quick to think that Abby
was taking advantage of JoJo's success
by asking her to appear on the show but
whether this is true or not doesn't seem
to bother Jojo whatsoever in the end
dodo is super excited about her guest
appearance and has stated will more
people tune in to watch season 8 episode
9 than ever before probably because well
who wouldn't want to see an original
cast member showing the new kids how
it's done but then again the guest
appearance will look good for both Abby
and Jojo
so it's a win-win if the producers of
the show had their way nearly every
single one of the original dancers would
be making guest appearances but most of
them would flat-out refuse due to their
estranged relationship with Abby only a
handful of Abby's students stuck by her
side when she was sent to jail and even
less made it a point to visit her in the
hospital when she was terminally ill in
an instant your life changes completely
knowing this Abby probably wouldn't even
want them on the show herself Jojo on
the other hand never felt a shower Abby
with support
she brought her gifts while she was at
the hospital raised money for her and
kept in touch with her throughout her
mini battles on top of that Abby thinks
that JoJo's personality is fun and
genuine and wants to broadcast it so
that young girls can remember to always
be themselves all in all working with
Jojo just makes a lot of sense
Abby's appeared on JoJo's YouTube
channel so why shouldn't Jojo repay the
favor by guest starring on her reality
TV show
unlike Abby and some of her former dance
students she and Jojo share a special
bond they make it a point to keep each
other close and are constantly spending
time with one another
Abby has spent Christmas with JoJo's
family and attended her sweet 16
birthday bash but there's a few that
have that star quality like Jojo on top
of that Abby and Jesslyn are also on
good terms so much so that Abby invited
Jojo and her mom to celebrate her 52nd
birthday with her Jojo is the only
original cast member who still chooses
to work with Abby because she's the only
one who sees her as a friend and an ally
a good friend like she's fine
so if you could choose one oh gee dancer
to appear on Dance Moms season 8 who
would it be and why tell us in the
comments give this video a big thumbs up
if you love Jojo see WA and be sure to
subscribe to the things for the latest
Dance Moms news see you next time thanks
for watching
[Music]